hey guys I'm back from New York you
probably don't even know I went to New
York because I don't think I've long
actually filmed some things never even
edited it and by the time I got back I
was like well this is no longer relevant
little Maggie got stung by a bee
yesterday and it was so tragic you were
so worried because I googled men all of
the results were like they can go into
anaphylactic shock within five minutes I
called the vet I was freaking out and
she's like is he is he breathing okay is
everything you see seemed alright I was
like yes but please see us immediately
thankfully they saw us and everything
was okay they got the Stinger out today
Joe shoot Leila brought me a coffee so
I'm gonna be on this show it's called
the runner and so on go 90 and this show
is wild they do this for 30 days
straight three times a day live and
there's these people all across the u.s.
running after somewhat well okay so it's
it's hard to explain
I'll have Matt explain it it's this
really awesome a nationwide manhunt for
this mysterious runner figure right
America learns small little details
about who this person is over time but
basically there are five chaser teams of
two who are all searching for this one
person who is trying to cross America
without being discovered I don't know
how you guys are doing this for so long
what is this this is episode number a
lot it's day 19 so it's times three it's
a lot of 30 days yeah this is why it's
funny for my shows game theory and film
theory we just crossed like 150 episodes
of game theory and this is gonna have
literally 30 days three episodes a day
what is that 90 episodes in one month oh
my god well good luck I'm gonna go home
I'll watch you later today
aside from time on the runner show today
I'm gonna put a link in the description
where you can watch my segment from
yesterday or today depending upon when
you're watching this Jenna is inside the
cake store here in the parking lot and
we're going to Francesca's birthday
party we're all heading to meet her and
go bowling so I'm excited about that
I haven't went bowling in a while but I
know I'm a pretty pro bowler so can only
expect the skills that we are gonna see
here tonight displayed by me I'm super
excited about the cake we're hoping that
it looks cool you guys might remember
her dog gizmo passed away a few months
ago well we got a cute little cake of
gizmo gizmo cake on the cake not really
sure what its gonna look like but I hope
it's cute sorry take don't wait
whoa I think this seats going off the
track yeah
the cake is seat belted in I want to see
a picture let me see let me see
it doesn't look at uncovered house like
real flower is a little hard morning
traffic good it's probably gonna take us
an hour to have to get there and I'm
really upset because I I wish the
Pokemon was a GPS so like I could put
the address in to illustrate
huh yeah I'm gonna just keep driving
so what I meant was I wish that I could
put a location Inc to my Pokemon at the
game and it would take us there like
it's like a GPS like Google Maps but
it's not do you know what I mean I do
like why don't they usually add this
it's really dangerous
well it's not like I'm hunting while I'm
driving yeah but what if like a pointy
otter 6000 popped up I keep calling go
need to lever the hell his name is
I keep calling and pointy otter because
I don't look at their names and I don't
know anything about Pokemon except what
Pokemon go has taught me which is point
Dianna look at this new thing I just
thought I thought this one Amazon it's
uh look at it it's I've not had a like a
a holder and so long it just like the
flips right on it's lightweight
Wow is there a link in the description
yeah I will open one you can fit an
iphone first theme song oh that makes
sense it expand expands its expanding
stretch out any further but I have a
here's a workout oh my gosh perfect I'm
floored to my being delivered and
although she was on crime day I'll get
you one
I'll get you one for your mouth is your
link in the description just see ok I
gotta put this camera out it's heavy
Oh does anybody wanna chat cuz I'm going
real slow what do you think of Charlie
it took us almost two hours to get here
like it took us so long we could have
drove to San Diego and back already
Dennis so concerned about the lineup of
the bowling and she's like they're gonna
the line if I'm to be tired and I want
to Bowl anymore
like I think you're gonna be all right
Jenn you'll be fine
so you guys missed it I got pressured
because it was my turn and I went and I
threw the ball like you would and guess
what I got
strike my first tried try the last one
I'm gonna get no it was
wasn't my best shot wasn't my best shot
I'm letting the team down myself is the
one person team
I really struggle in here
you can't see it because is a wide-angle
lens I can't zoom any further ready to
light this up and heat it
right
Jeff can take bullying very seriously
actually anything competitive she gets
mad out of all the corners
expectable perfect
thank God I was scared for my life
we just got back from bowling I realized
I'm really bad at bowling I'm not sure
if it's because I don't try it's
probably why I got a few items to make
iced coffee I'm pretty excited about it
I think I might do a video on the proper
ways to make iced coffee you know I love
going to coffee shops but there are
times that I'm at home and I work from
home so often that like I don't want to
go out and get the coffee I can just
make it here we're sneaky puppet get me
puppet there we go there's pinkie puppet
Wow can you pick you puppet is this
pinkie puppet is it back
oh gosh hey hey hey
sit sit sit
catch good boy oh my prince my prince
see you guys tomorrow bye so I had to
stop the video because you see give me
so long to cut